das ist mir gerade viel zu ruhig
es ist mir
was war das
hallo ich meine lieben villiger buddies
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
minecraft horror map und zwar die
monetary in minecraft der downloadlink
ist in der beschreibung heißt es selber
spielen wollt ich habe alles ein
bisschen angepasst also erstmal die
mystery heißt zu deutsch übersetzt so
was wie minecraft das kloster oder so
das sehen wir auch noch mal über kam
simon ist das ganze nochmals ein
bisschen erklärt dass ich mir gar nicht
durchgelesen also die map ist ins bei
dem und dem dass das resort spa way you
can't braker niblock olivers express und
hier haben wir nämlich schon glas und
hier steht für really happy slapping
insel skiathos tat
ich glaube aber wieder viel zu viel
drumherum ich möchte erstmal ganz kurz
sagen was für viel zu viel rum ich bin
einfach direkt drin
hier findet alle links in der
beschreibung ich selber hab das ganze so
ein bisschen jetzt mit der charakter
noch angepasst als eventuell ein
bisschen gruselig wird eigentlich kann
man minecraft janson gruseleffekt
erzeugen aber ich will das mal sagen
hier muss auf jeden fall
darauf haben wir erstmal in sachen drin
also ich hab das ganze ein bisschen
schneller gemacht gleich das ganze hat
relativ relativ viel wasser war drin
schon drei seiten
es ist nämlich eine mordserie das ist so
ein kloster und weil ich das jetzt
umsetzen kann ist es halt so dass in
diesem kloster wohl irgend eine macht
ist die sogar hitler damals schon beim
zweiten weltkrieg für sich haben wollte
allerdings war die macht an so groß dass
er irgendwie selbstmord begangen hat
soweit ich das richtig verstanden ist
das alles sehr absurd ich würde sagen
'ich packe man den schalter drauf wir
legen den schalter mal um
ich habe schon so komische geräusche
hier das sind eisentüren die kann ich
nicht öffnen ließ aber so einen weg
alter ist es gerade helllichten tag und
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass so was
irgendwie gruselig sein kann aber durch
die musik ist das schon so ein wenig
gerade alles schon krank übrigens leute
ich hab mir gedacht ich mach erst mal
eine folge lade die hoch und schaue wie
sie ankommt und wenn ihr wollt mache ich
noch eine zweite und sonst könnt ihr die
map weiter spielen also gebt mal daumen
hoch
ganz viele daumen hoch und dann wenn das
relativ viele sind dann schaue ich mal
ob ich dann noch eventuell ja noch eine
zweite folge mache da kommst oder
mystery okay wir bei den katakomben
nicht wirklich ein weg ist was hab ich
überhaupt ich habe langsamkeit und blind
alternativ eine rüstung sieht auch
richtig toll aus und greift sagt der
folge winter erzielt
ich würde sagen mir jemals im monasteria
sie zum kloster das ist dann dieser weg
ich will hier nicht lang gehen ich will
hier nicht lang gehen
alter jetzt sogleich am liebsten würde
ich mich ins amt rang holen als ganz
neuen creative durchfliegen
hallo hier bin ich ich bin drin
okay ich bin drin wo soll ich denn jetzt
lang was für gerüche wahr
was sind das für geräusche man wie krank
ist das denn
ich sehe ja nahezu nichts lief als
baulmann oma was das hier ist sondern
höher
bin ich jetzt hier runter gefallen oha
ich sehe einfach nichts
es ist halt ich werde älter softbox
angeleuchtet und so sind dass sie für
dinge was geht hier vor wo bin ich
wie die dass sie weiter
ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung wo ich
bin
ich weiß echt nicht wo ich bin ich weiß
nicht wo ich lange muss
ich gebe einfach hier wieder zurück
all das ist mir viel zu ruhig hier es
ist mir gerade viel zu ruhig
es ist mir das war das
das kann nicht sein hier ist nicht mal
musik gerade ich will das nicht spielen
ich hasse horror spiele ich kann das gar
nicht ab ich aber wenn ich wenigstens
mal ein wenig was ihn würde wäre es ja
schon ganz schön hier kann ich hoch
hüpfen
doch nicht
ok hatten fenster gefunden
cool wo muss ich hier lang
ich weiß überhaupt nicht wo ich lange
muss ich schleiche hat ihn sein weg
entlang
ich muss diese partikel irgendwie auch
ständig kriegt die ganze dieses komische
blubbern in wenn meine fresse rein aber
ich weiß nicht ich das aus stelle
egal ich habe es euch in die kommentare
geschrieben ob ihr das wollt und wie das
eventuell geht könnt ihr mir da
eventuell weiterhelfen
ich weiß das muss doch irgendwas zu
bedeuten haben oder finde ich einfach
ohne grund irgend so ein fenster
das ist eine leiter
ich will mich nicht umdrehen wo bin ich
wo bin ich freunde ich will hier nicht
runter bitte macht wenigstens die musik
wieder an
es ist einfach gerade so leise eventuell
dragset die obmänner story in city and
press button
was für insel key ich hab keinen key
woher soll ich denn den key bekommen
freunde
irgendwo hier muss also ein kiwi
irgendwo hier oder muss ich erst in die
katakomben gehen
ich klettere hier ist mal wieder hoch
wir wissen also auf jeden fall ist erst
mal nichts ist außer dieser raum wo ich
dachte kommt zehn millionen monster
ich hoffe jetzt erst mal ich glaube hier
dann ging es zurück
ich laufe jetzt einfach mal ein
stückchen
ich bin nur gegen den kopf dagegen
offenbar wo wir müssen wieder diese
dieser komische
wo bin ich weiter heftig wo muss ich
lange hier gibt's ein stücklein rein da
als das ist wieder dieses lief ihr ziel
dieser teppich sollte man erst mal ich
geh mal wieder raus
ich dachte ich komme nicht mehr aus
ich gehe mal eben in die katakomben
eventuell muss sich daher zuerst hin
wenn ich nie meine story
geld her
ich glaube ich habe jetzt einfach mal so
selber ein bisschen ich glaub ich hab
grad einfach sich im thalia hat einfach
mal selber so ein bisschen musik weil
das ganze gerade relativ ruhig ist oder
ich gehe einfach mal zuerst jetzt in die
in die katakomben rein
hier kommt der zettel das schild aracom
okay ich gebe hier lang ist er weg
leider nicht dass es bei den katakomben
ihren chancen ist ich glaube sollte sich
bei den acht spielen
leider kommt ja okay da brauche ich auch
in köln
ich glaube ich muss wirklich zuerst in
die ministerien und der linken tief in
de
so nochmal rein so jetzt ist jeder
teppich ich sehe halt nichts mehr weil
ich dieses ich mach mal ganz kurz das
hier auf 17
das bringt ja auch nix ich habe einfach
dieses sichtweite effekt ja blind hat
man diese partikel regen mich halt ein
bisschen auf kann ich die nicht
irgendwie aufstellen die man in
grafikeinstellungen fox fox channel dass
die bewegung louis war ich beleuchtung
grafik modus muss mein bild ich weiß
halt nicht wo hier irgendwie partikel
steht deswegen wenn ihr mir das
schreiben könnte es richtig cool
aber ich weiß gar nicht wo ich weiter
gegangen muss ich muss irgendwie hier
ist dieser teppich und ich muss halt
irgendwie seinen schlüssel finden
da steht einfach nur lief ich hoffe
jetzt mal hier links daran vorbei hier
geht's lang
der ok sind wir wieder genau an
diesen ganzen jahr und jetzt endlich
wieder laufen ich sehe nichts ich zähle
nichts freunde ja okay hier kann ich
lang bin ich hier okay ich glaube jetzt
einfach um klopp jetzt einfach mal so
ein bisschen durch diese wege die sich
mir hier mal wieder am start
glock musst beim abspielen dass ich ein
wenig was sehen kann aber man kann echt
nicht sehen
ich möchte dieses ganze noch nicht
weiterspielen grad früheren als diese
musik noch an weil ich mir so in die
hosen machen können
ich sehe nichts aus erzählt
glock ich brauche da nur ein schlüssel
nicht irgendwas nicht das auch nichts oh
mann
freundlich aber twitter gefragt was sie
sehen wollten da meinten die horror
karten leute ich brauchen schlüssel
wo kriegt den her ich sehe nichts da
oben ist die decke hier oben sind aber
auch da ist ja nicht so dass intel diese
quasi diese fenster kann diese blindheit
effekt nicht einfach mal weg gehen
wir müssen jetzt mal hier die anpacken
und jetzt geht es ja jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt zwar auf einem himmel rum und
jetzt guck ich immer hoch jetzt bin ich
wieder beim fenster kann die leiter
runter gehen und hier unten haben wir ja
schon jetzt stehe ich müssen ich muss
ein schlüssel mitnehmen aber wo ist der
schlüssel
die obmänner story insel ski and press
paten
in scott key ich musste im schlüssel
wahrscheinlich irgendwie
irgendwo hier ist glas muss denn
muss auch nicht jeder ist nichts
ja ich brauch irgendwie schlüssel ich
muss in dem schlüssel finden
ich würde allerdings sagen dass das
jetzt erst mal schon mal die erste folge
war eine zweite folge wollt dann s p den
daumen nach oben und eventuell also
keine spoiler schreiben aber enthält
tipps beispielsweise um der schlüssel
ist wirklich in der monster rede mussten
weiter suchen oder irgendwie sowas
und dann schaue ich mir das heute mal an
wie das bei euch angekommen ist und ich
muss jetzt eventuell noch zu irgendeinem
ort kommen wo ich weiß dass ich das
keiner gesehen ist das handy zu spielen
das hat sich schon mal das ein nettes
personal da müsste ich ja theoretisch
das ist auch einfach eine treppe
das war auch eine treppe und ich bin
jetzt hier unsere bücher links
okay das war nur der tisch agp was
aktiviert die man ich sehe halt einfach
nichts ich sehe das hier bücher sind und
mir nicht das fenster mehr sehe ich ja
nicht
sie den boden
was geht noch weiter nach oben welche
den boden dürfte weiter nach oben
alter denken wir die musiker
wahrscheinlich schon die ganze musik
okay es ist hier einfach schon wieder so
ein hier geht es noch weiter nach oben
freunde hier geht es noch weiter nach
oben ich würde allerdings sagen dass man
menschen in der nächsten folge da oben
wird wahrscheinlich in black ii sein
bitte nicht spoilern falls die map schon
irgendwie kennt ich gehe jetzt erstmal
raus wenn es euch gefallen hat und die
eventuell morgen die zweite folge haben
wollt dann zeigt man mit einer bewertung
und dann sehen wir uns da wieder